car au moment des millions de bébés des
millions de bébés ils sont intoxiqués
par les smartphones pas par les ondes
des étoiles mais parce qu'ils prennent
les smartphones de leurs parents les
parents font pas attention le bébé à la
trappe
ils se mettent à s'en servir et quand on
veut leur enlever il se met à hurler ils
sont incontrôlables
il devient addict aux smartphones est
très très très vite et c'est presque
aussi terrible que le crack est une
drogue encore pire que l'héroïne canton
quand on prend une dose de crack on ne
peut plus s'en passer
alors qu'est-ce que ça produit sa nièce
a produit ce qu'on appelle le l'autisme
en fait c'est pas vraiment de l'autisme
aimé ça produit des enfants qui à deux
ans et demi trois ans ne parle pas ne
regarde pas quand vous leur parlez et
non pas de motricité et sont
complètement confirmée en ml
explique-t-on scientifiquement pas ça
c'est un phénomène
ça c'est en fait assez bien expliqué moi
même je travaille depuis très longtemps
sur ces questions et en particulier avec
une américaine qui est à stanford
d'aujourd'hui qui s'appelle marianne
wolf on a publié un livre ensemble en
france et d'ailleurs et lé
neuropsychologue et elle a très bien
montré comment ce qu'on appelle la chine
à ptuj nerfs du cerveau infantile il ya
des conditions pour qu'elle se produit
dans de bonnes dans nos bonnes il faut
que des relations d'abord très très
important il faut que les normands des
changes
le mythe de tarzan est un mythe un
enfant qui est vrai qu'il serait levé
par des singes ne verrait jamais sosa
veut se développer dans votre cas
l'enfant n'est pas élevé par un
smartphone il n'en est par contre le
d'abord les parents eux mêmes sont
toujours sur leur smartphone c'est là
que ça commence en fait le problème
le bébé voyons ses parents son père et
sa mère sur les smartphones il veut
avoir aussi un smartphone il veut
prendre le smartphone et puis on le lui
donne quand il est sur le smartphone il
est très calme en apparence et dès qu'on
lui enlève il fait une crise est au bout
de deux ans dans s'aperçoit qu'ils
parlent pas donc on l'amène à maternelle
elle la maternelle téléphone aux parents
mais vous savez votre enfant ils valent
pas donc ne pas le prendre
ne pas s'occuper de lui et c'est des cas
comme ça il y en a des millions
aujourd'hui c'est une épidémie mondiale
[Musique]